PETE: WE’RE BACK WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT COMMUNIST CHINA SENDING
MIXED MESSAGES ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP’S COVID-19 DIAGNOSIS.
WHILE CHINESE XI-JINPING WISHES
OUR PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY A
FAST RECOVERY IN A NOW-DELETED
TWEET THE EDITOR IN C CHIEF OF O
OF CHINA’S STATE-RUN MEDIA
OUTLETS THERE ARE NO OTHER KIND
IN CHINA, MOCKED PRESIDENT TRUMP
, CLAIMING HE "PAYS THE
PRICE FOR HIS GAMBLE TO PLAY
DOWN COVID-19".
LET’S BRING IN FOX NEWS SENIOR
STRATEGIC ANALYST AND RETIRED
FOUR STAR GENERAL JACK KEANE.
GENENERAL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT’S PRETTY RICH FOR THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE TO BE
TALKING ABOUT PLAYING DOWN A
VIRUS THAT THEY PUT ON THE REST
OF THE WORLD AND STATE-OWNED
MEDIA DON’T SAY THINGS
INDEPENDENTLY.
WHAT ARE THE CHINESE SAYING AND
HOW SHOULD WE REACT TO IT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I MEAN,
THERE IS AN INTERNATIONAL
PROTOCOL THAT’S WIDELY ACCEPTED
AMONG LEADERS OF THE WORLD WHEN
ONE OF THEM IS HAVING A
CHALLENGE LIKE OUR PRESIDENT HAS
, THEY’RE GOING TO REACH OUT
WITH A DEGREE OF CIVILITY AND
SUPPORT FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS WIFE, THE FIRST LADY.
ALL THAT SAID, BECAUSE PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS BEEN UNRELENTING AS A
WORLD LEADER IN IDENTIFYING, I
THINK, ACCURATELY SO, THAT CHINA
, AND ITS LEADER, PRESIDENT
XI LED A LOCALIZED
EPIDEMIC SPREAD INTO A WORLD
PANDEMIC, BECAUSE HE COMMITTED
THOSE INTERNATIONAL FLIGHTS TO
COME OUT OF WUHAN CITY AND WE
HAVE HELD THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND
NOW THERE’S A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT FOR THAT SAME THOUGHT
PROCESS AND I ALSO BELIEVE ITS
BEEN A CATALYST FOR OTHER
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD, PETE
, TO KIND OF TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY, AND
REASSESS IT IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEIR GOALS ARE AND WHAT THEIR
OWN NATIONAL INTERESTS ARE AND
THAT REASSESSMENT HAS TAKEN
PLACE AND THAT’S WHY YOU SEE
SECRETARY POMPEO GOING
AROUND THE WORLD AS MUCH AS HE
IS AND SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
ESPER AS WELL.
THEY ARE CONTINUOUSLY TALKING
ABOUT THIS HOSTILE NATION CHINA
AND IMPOSING ITS WILL ON THE
WORLD AT LARGE AND NOW, I
THINK WE’RE IN A POSITION HERE
THAT WE’VE NOT BEEN BEFORE IN
ESTABLISHING A COALITION AND
EVENTUALLY A STRATEGY WITH OTHER
WORLD LEADERS IN HOW TO COPE
WITH THIS REALITY.
PETE: BUT GENERAL WOULD THAT
CHANGE IN A BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IT DOESN’T SEEM THERE’S BEEN ANY
REASSESSMENT THERE.
HE CALLS THEM A COMPETITOR.
ARE THEY, WOULD THEY BE GREETED
WITH A MUCH-DIFFERENT WORLD WERE
THAT TO HAPPEN?
>> PETE I DON’T GET INVOLVED IN
THE POLITICS OF THIS.
THE REALITY IS CHINA WANTS TO
DOMINATE AND CONTROL THEIR
REGION, AND THEY HAVE BEEN ABOUT
THAT NOW, FOR ABOUT 15 YEARS AND
THEY’VE HAD A SIGNIFICANT --
PETE: GENERAL I DON’T WANT TO
GET POLITICAL --
>> AND AS A RESULT OF THAT
SUCCESS, THEY ALSO WANT TO GET
UP, THEY ALSO WANT TO
DOMINATE THE WORLD AND REPLACE
THE UNITED STATES AS A LEADER IN
THE WORLD, SO THAT IS NOT GOING
TO CHANGE REGARDLESS OF WHO IS
PRESIDENT.
THOSE ARE VERY HARSH REALITIES.
WE HAVE NOT FACED A THREAT LIKE
THIS , LIKE SINCE THE SOVIET
UNION.
ITS BEEN 30 YEARS ALMOST SINCE
THE SOVIET UNION COLLAPSED, AND
WE DEALT WITH THAT THREAT FOR 40
YEARS.
WE’RE GOING TO DEAL WITH THE
THREAT OF CHINA ALSO FOR
MULTIPLE GENERATIONS.
PETE: GENERAL WE KNOW YOU SPEAK
WITH THE PRESIDENT FREQUENTLY,
HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
HIM AND GET AN  ASSESSMENT AND
SORT OF A COROLLARY TO THAT, AS
YOU THINK IN A MOMENT LIKE
THIS HOW DO YOU ANTICIPATE WHAT
ADVERSARIES MAY ATTEMPT TO DO AS
THEY VIEW OUR SYSTEM AND A
PRESIDENT WHOSE AT WALTER REED?
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT DOESN’T
SURPRISE ME AT ALL IN DEALING
WITH COVID.
HE’S VIGOROUS, HE’S MAINTAINING
HIS DUTIES, HE’S GOT A VERY
STRONG WORK ETHIC, I’M NOT
SURPRISED BY THAT AT ALL, AND
CERTAINLY, I THINK WE’RE ALL
APPRECIATE THE OPTIMISM THAT HIS
DOCTORS ARE TELLING US THAT HE’S
DOING WELL AND HE’S IMPROVING
AND HE’S NOT OUT OF THE WOODS
YET AS WE ALL KNOW WHAT COVID
DOES.
YES OUR ADVERSARIES CERTAINLY
OUR NATIONAL COMMAND AUTHORITY,
OUR COMMAND AND CONTROL OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY APPARATUS THAT
STAYS INTACT.
IT’S NOT IN CRISIS.
IT’S NOT THREATENED BY THIS.
DIPLOMATIC POST THE MILITARY IS
DEPLOYED AND OPERATING AROUND
THE WORLD ON A SAME ALERT STATUS
IT ALWAYS IS, AND OUR COMMAND
AND CONTROL IS EFFECTIVE AND
THERE SHOULD BE NO CONCERN, BUT
ADVERSARIES AS YOU MENTIONED,
PETE WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
ONE OF THE THINGS I’M CONVINCED
THEY WILL DO BECAUSE THEY ARE
ALREADY DOING IT AND THAT IS
UNDERMINING OUR DEMOCRACY AND
UNDERMINE THE PEOPLE’S TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE IN IT BY SPREADING
FALSE STORIES AND DISINFORMATION
WHICH THEY’VE BEEN WORKING ON
FOR MONTNTHS, LEADING UP TO THE
ELECTION AND WHOSE DOING THAT?
CHINA IS DOING IT, RUSSIA, AND
ALSO, IRAN.
THEY WILL TRY TO CHANGE THEIR
STORIES A LITTLE BIT, BLAME THE
PRESIDENT FOR HAVING COVID
HIMSELF, EMPHASIZE AGAIN THE
UNITED STATES PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH COVID, BLAME THE
UNITED STATES FOR MUCH OF
THE PROBLEM DEALING WITH COVID
WORLDWIDE.
THEY WILL USE THAT KIND OF THEME
TO CREATE MISS TRUST IN THE
AMERICAN’S PEOPLE’S
CONFIDENCE IN OUR GOVERNMENT BUT
THE PEOPLE SEE THROUGH THAT AND
THEY’RE NOT BUYING INTO THAT AND
THE REALITY IS WE’RE KIND OF
USED TO THIS GAME THAT OUR
ADVERSARIES ARE PLAYING AND THE
INFORMATION INFLUENCE
BUSINESS.
PETE: YEAH, JUST LIKE WE BECOME
UNFORTUNATELY USED TO THE GAME A
LOT OF THE PRESS PLAYS TO KNIT
PICKING IN WHAT DOESN’T APPEAR
TO BE ALL THAT GENUINE OF A WAY.
GENERAL JACK KEANE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, FOR YOUR INSIGHT THIS